the department of energy released
another 15 million barrels from the
Strategic petroleum Reserve extending
our previously announced release through
the month of December right now the
Strategic polymer strategic petroleum
Reserve is more than half full with
about 400 million barrels of oil
that's more than enough for any
emergency drawdown
okay when he mumbled through that what
he didn't mention is that the Strategic
petroleum Reserve is now at its lowest
point in 40 years now replenishing it is
going to take a lot of time and cost
Americans a boatload of money but he
doesn't care he doesn't even understand
where he is the main point is that this
is not what the reserve was made for
now it was conceived to protect all
Americans in an emerging crisis not the
Democratic party ahead of the midterms
joining us now is Steve Malloy former
Trump EPA transition member founder of
junk science.com Steve since no one else
in the media will we're going to take
the audience through a few statements
Biden made today at his big energy talk
and then we're going to fact check them
let's begin with this okay my
Administration has not stopped or slowed
U.S oil production
quite the opposite you can increase oil
and gas production now while still
moving Full Speed Ahead to accelerate
our transition to clean energy
Steve is that true
that's totally false from day one you
know he shut down pipelines he has shut
down uh leasing on federal lands he's
got the Federal Reserve trying to stop
lending to the oil industry he's
threatening the oil industry with price
gouging investigations criminal
investigations Congress democrat
congress is doing the same thing he's
shutting down LNG terminals he's
shutting down oil storage facilities he
is doing everything he can to shut the
oil industry down to discourage Drilling
well Biden also leveled another
criticism today
my message to American energy companies
is this you should not be using your
profits to buy back stock or for
dividends not now not while a war is
Raging
Steve is that happen
well
will drilling so much oil production so
much that oil companies are actually
buying back their stock which is already
at record prices so what does that say
when they would rather buy back their
own stock than sell oil which is also at
very high prices I mean he is doing
nothing to encourage oil production he's
doing everything to discourage it and
Biden also resorted uh Steve to his
favorite scapegoat for high prices watch
this
I have been doing everything in my power
to reduce gas prices since Putin's
invasion of Ukraine caused these price
hikes these prices to spike and rattle
International oil markets
um the coughing came
um so he's done everything in his power
to reduce gas prices but and also what's
your best estimate for how much
um uh this war is actually contributing
to these high prices
yeah he he he's done nothing
um we went through earlier the list of
things he's not done and the Strategic
petroleum Gambit uh that's not reducing
the price of oil although he's taking
credit for it all it's doing is going to
make Americans uh pay more for gas for
oil later as he has to replenish it you
know we need that strategic petroleum
reserve for actual emergencies not just
re-electing Democrats and and just to
get back to this point there have been
no offshore lease sales
right since he's been in office uh for
for oil there's no offshore releases at
all
though he's he has he has completely
shut down leasing uh they've been in
court about this uh they have not gotten
it straight yet uh but you know they are
not encouraging any sort of drilling
despite the fact that you know they got
Joe manchin to agree to that inflation
reduction act with the promise of more
oil drilling but that's not happening
yeah Lucy and the football on that Steve
great to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else